Speaker 1: Failed former Vice President Mike
Pence, who is as much who basically failed as
hard as Trump did, has been asked about
the verdict in which a jury found Donald
Trump liable for sexual assault and defamation
against Jean Carroll. Mike Pence's reaction is,
I dare say, Kafkaesque. He says he
never saw Trump sexually assault anyone.
Think about that for a second. What do
you think about that verdict? Listen,
I never saw Trump sexually assault anybody. Wow.
Big declaration, Mike. Thank you. Let's listen.
Speaker 4: In my four and a half years
serving alongside the president, I never
heard or witnessed behavior of that nature.
Speaker 1: I never personally witnessed Charles
Manson encourage those people to go and kill
anybody. He must not have done it right. A truly
spineless response from Mike Pence. We also
had Pence weighing in on whether the American
people will in any way be influenced by the fact
that Trump now is not only has been arrested and
indicted and might be arrested and indicted
again in a couple of months, but was found
liable for sexual assault. He says Pence does.
He doesn't think the American people will care.
Speaker 4: Well, I think that's a question for the
American people. But I, I really can't comment on
a judgment in a civil case. I have no knowledge
of those matters. And I'm sure the president will
defend himself in that matter. And but it strikes
me that we it's it's just one more instance where
at a time when American families are struggling.
Speaker 1: He's really he's really struggling
to figure out what to say about this, to remain
palatable to the MAGA crowd in case he does run.
Speaker 4: When our economy is hurting, when
the world seems to become a more dangerous place
almost every day, that it's it's just one more
story. Focusing on my former running mate that
that I know is a great fascination to members of
the national media. But I just I just don't think
it's fair to the American people are focused.
Speaker 1: All right? The American people don't
care because of inflation, I guess, or something
along those lines. To me, that sounds like a guy
who wants to say whatever he can say to not anger
the very MAGA people who maybe if Trump gets
arrested again and his campaign falls apart for
whatever reason, Pence can jump in and say, I'm
going to run MAGA. People who supported Trump back
when I was VP. Come with me to the Promised Land
or whatever the case may be, may be one of the
most cowardly, spineless and self-serving people
in American politics right now would be indeed
Mike Pence. And that the height of absurdity of
I never saw him engage in that sort of behavior
and really does. Do you think he does? Does a
serial sexual assaulter habitually do the
assaulting in front of other men? I mean,
I don't know. There was the allegation about
Jeffrey Epstein and Trump doing exactly that,
but not the vast majority of the allegations
that exist. So PENCE Pathetic is always polling
like three or 4% in most polls, six, seven in
some. And maybe thinking opportunistically is
this. Let's leave it with the question that
was asked. Will that civil liability verdict.
Affect Trump's standing in either the primary
or the general. I actually agree that the answer
is no, but for a different reason than Mike
Pence says. I think in the primary it won't
affect Trump, at least not negatively, because
for as many people in the Republican primary
voter electorate, that would be turned off by
Trump being liable for sexual assault. There
are those who will be reengaged because they
believe Trump is being treated unfairly and
that it's all a political witch hunt. So in the
primary, it'll probably be flat in the general.
I think that the cake is more or less baked
than it's basically a turn out thing. And
maybe there are some people who would turn out
because they're angry that Trump engaged in this
behavior and they want to vote against him.
But it's also not clear to me that it's going
to shift the numbers in a general election
either. I know it's crazy. I know it's crazy,
but that's where my head is right now. Let me know
what you think. The David Pacman Show continues
to be a viewer and listener funded program. We
depend on your support. Through the membership
program you can avail yourself of membership
benefits at join Pacman dot com, which is just an
extraordinary place to sign up for membership.
It's quite frankly the only place they tell me
these days. You can use the coupon code indicted
or the coupon code indicated whichever you want.